this morning we have an inside look at
how digital warriors inside ukraine and
beyond are fighting russia's economy and
working to starve russia's resources
they've been very effective more than
400 companies have stopped doing
business in russia since its troops
invaded ukraine nearly a month ago and
ukrainian leaders are now also pressing
major tech companies to block services
in russia and to create a so-called
digital blockade apple google and
microsoft have already done that
joining us now from inside ukraine is
that country's deputy minister of
digital transformation alex bornyakov mr
deputy minister good morning to you
before we get to what many people are
calling a new way of war i want to ask
about you personally we're not saying
where you are for your own safety
what is your life like these days how
are you sleeping uh just tell us about
the conditions you're living through
right now
well hi everyone so yeah
when it's all started i was in cave and
i was
i woke up from explosions it was like
six a.m
and i spent two days in cave and it was
horrible there was
air strikes
explosions jets are flying
and we managed to
evacuate because it was impossible to
work but we have to restore the work of
the ministry in order to deliver
services to people and do what we do
right now what you call digital volcano
we call this digital diplomacy
um i'm i'm still in ukraine um and um
pretty much far of their actual war zone
but still even where i am there are
sirens and um and the threat of
airstrikes still so from time to time we
have to go to shelter
but so far i'm good
are you concerned about being personally
targeted
because of what you're doing
um well of course and
today's night
telegram account was was there was there
was
people who wanted to compromise my
account
and i think that's that's what they're
trying to do
in the first place to figure out where
we are and uh
and what we're talking about and what
our plans are
so mr deputy minister uh about that new
method of war it's kind of you call it
diplomacy other people call it a kind of
digital warfare uh you're using a mix of
social media pressure campaigns uh and
digital currency cryptocurrency to
create pressure on companies to get out
of russia create this blockade and also
bring in funds uh tell us about this
digital future when it comes to warfare
how is it working how did you come up
with it the whole story
well as it started uh
all from from the
from the fact that we realized that we
can't stop this
russian war machine
uh
because it's it's so much it's it's so
big it's so it's so many troops so we
decided to fight on the economic and
digital front because we believe that uh
if we stop uh taxpayers paying uh
money to government which which they
spend not to develop their
infrastructure not to build schools not
to build hospitals not to build roads
but they use this money to invade their
neighbors to threat
all the european countries in the world
so we have to stop
money flows to russia and this was the
vision uh that came up to
uh nicole further during the first day
so we formed are a group of people that
started immediately to act um and uh
maybe you're not aware but twitter is
not popular in ukraine but we realize
that it's pretty much popular in in the
state so we decided to appeal to to to
the governments to or to private
companies and specifically to digital
ones because we are uh you can find more
expertise than digital ministry of
digital transformation in ukraine in
terms of working with their tech giants
and so we started to talk to them and
showing them this this is not just
because uh they invaded ukraine they
possess threat to the whole europe today
and um how it works so we basically
trying to establish personal contacts
with their and using and using of course
the context that we already had before
to show the real situation in ukraine
what's what's going on and and share our
vision through
email to phone calls through
social media and we're doing this on the
instant basis like
in in in zoom conversations in in chains
using introductions
deputy minister um as tony mentioned
earlier more than 400 businesses have
already announced their withdrawal from
russia so what is your message to
businesses and tech companies that are
still doing business in or with russia
our message is that those money that you
pay to russian government
they spend to kill civilian people
to
fund the war machine to fund their
propaganda machine and they use this
government money not for the good of
russian people
they use it for aggression
and create a threat for the whole world
for this
for
what we have what what we had for the
last uh decades like which was a
peaceful world where oakley will can
travel
and now uh three million refugees in uh
europe in in america of course part of
them
and
you you can't support this uh regime
with your money even your private
institution
yeah you have to
aware of their morality of of those
actions today it's it's not just it's of
course it's about ukraine but it's not
just about ukraine it's about
showing the aggressor that those actions
are unacceptable
in 21st century you can't just in the
middle of europe start invading country
with their absurd
background of like special military
operation
and kill thousands of people
that's just
yes mr deputy minister uh we appreciate
you walking us through it as the war in
physical space continues you're waging
it uh from an undisclosed location
digitally uh we appreciate you spending
some time with us this morning and the
american people are with you the polls
here in this country show the american
people are with you that's right they
are all right thank you so much very
much
thank you